this has a box that you're going to
throw in the garbage unless you have a
hamster that you're going to put in here
um I'm like it's a pla it's a paper box
this is going right back and getting
returned because it's a scam Bethany
Frankel slamming Kylie Jenner don't hit
the player hit the game the former Bravo
star turned Beauty blogger of sorts
calling out the lip kit Creator's latest
launch you're always gonna have haters
and negative comments so we try not to
read them or maybe watch them in the
case of Bethany's Tick Tock takedown the
skinny girl Mogul telling her followers
not to buy Kylie's birthday themed PR
box set calling it a scam girl don't do
it is now worth it this is Kylie's
birthday PR package with the same two
products as these
this is 58 this is a hundred and seventy
five dollars
I'm confused so I'm gonna keep these
which are 58 because they're cute and
because
I bought them this is going right back
and getting returned because it's a scam
yeah not so sure about that breaking
news this just in I just found out that
Kylie Beauty does not accept returns so
I am stuck with a 117 dollar card board
box
maybe I'll go to the mall and get myself
a hamster can someone help me understand
let me just see something hold on how
stupid do we have to be like I just want
to know like how stupid do we have to be
okay
I mean I'm a sucker I like it I like the
packaging I like the stuff but you know
where you lose me
is when you scammed me ET has reached
out to Kylie's team for comment
this isn't the first time Bethany shared
her honest opinion about a Kardashian
Jenner product Oh my God it's a Rubik's
Cube hear that sound yeah just last
month she reviewed Kim's skin care line
as far as the eye cream luxurious
product very nice I feel like for this
price tag it would be Sean takai Sicily
Rich it's not Kardashian Rich it's
richer than I am maybe but it's not
Kardashian rich but it's not all snark b
sometimes has something nice to say this
is definitely good skincare I just think
it's extremely impractical thank you
foreign